[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
head coach of the fighting irish at
notre dame with the double overtime win
against clemson
next up will be boston college on
saturday at boston college coach
congratulations
have you looked at the game film
broke that down yesterday dan we uh
we're already on to uh
bc to uh steal a bill belichick line
how long did it take you to pronounce dj
uyangalalay's name
still haven't got to the uh
you just called him dj or that number
five
that really really good quarterback uh i
told davo i said i'd like to have your
problems
both those quarterbacks i don't know how
they get any better with either one of
them i mean they're just
two outstanding quarterbacks how do you
prepare differently
or did you prepare differently you know
the system of offense kind of you know
is what it is i mean they've been
running the same whether
desean watson was the quarterback or um
you know trevor or or dj uh
you know you're really defending the
system and then the player makes it
you know obviously go and and both of
them are just outstanding players
i didn't know if you picked your poison
with travis etienne it's either
i'm gonna let him be a runner or i'm
going to let him be a pass receiver what
was the uh
the defensive philosophy
well it's a little bit of both i mean
you can't you know
you're really in a position where
matching him up one-on-one with your
linebacker is not a good
up so we had to keep a safety in a
position where he could get some help
over the top as well so
you know obviously you could tell by our
game plan you know travis etienne was
was a guy that we were focused on uh
they have other weapons that
uh certainly hurt us uh and and that
that's really the nature of playing the
number one team in the country
they have more ways to beat you than
just uh just one guy but uh we felt like
travis set dan was the guy that we
really had to focus on
the late fumble by ian book and i don't
know as a coach
do you need to say something is it
sometimes better to not say something to
the player who just
coughed up the football you know his his
resume
you know does not get the kind of
scrutiny that it should
he leads us to so many late comebacks
and wins you know as somebody that's
27 3 as a starter you have to win a lot
of games late and so
i thought it was appropriate that time
to go up and say hey you're going to win
a game for us here
we're going to need you to do that again
and so
i just thought the timing was
appropriate to give him some positive
reinforcement at that time
and you know again he did what he's done
so many times for us he led a
a 91-yard drive uh with under two
minutes in the game um
you know to get the you know the tie
replay is killing the game coach
oh tell me about it you you're preaching
to the choir
how did we get here uh
this would be a long interview if we
really wanted to get into it
um i i think we
have really over analyzed the game to
the extent
that um you know everybody wants to be
perfect and
there's nothing perfect about any sport
it still has that that element of
uh you're going to miss a couple here
and there you just hope you don't miss
them big
and i think we're trying to be perfect
and you can't be perfect in the game and
perfection is slowing this game down to
a point where it
is absolutely brutal if i said to the
coaches you vote you can have replay or
no replay
uh i would say can we just have replay
on scoring plays you know where where
they can
be absolutely uh you know game changers
but to
to be nitpicking every single play
is just look there were so many
stoppages in that game
i felt bad for the guy the poor kids
kick in the extra points in overtime
i mean i could hear myself breathing in
overtime
there's nobody in the stands and those
kids are kicking extra points and
they're stopping the game for four
minutes to
to replay again and again again it was
uh
it's got to change it it was it was
unfortunate okay
the fans come on the field now where
were all those fans during the game
are those all in the stands or those on
campus yeah no they were
no no they were in the no
we're not that good um no they were the
fans in the stands
and look our our job obviously in that
situation is to do the best we can to
keep them from going on the field
you know we protected uh you know
clemson i had alluded to my team that uh
when we win this game that they're gonna
like most fans throughout the country
they're gonna they're gonna come onto
the field
it was their last home game because we
closed down school next week
it was really their last home game
because they won't be here for the
december 5th game against stan
uh syracuse excuse me so they took the
opportunity to come on the field
and uh you know we did the best we could
under those circumstances
yeah it reminded me of justin turner in
the world series that
emotion overtakes common sense
yeah i look again would we have liked it
to have been different yes all those
students were tested
earlier in the week for kovid
you know again it's hard to
stop students coming over the fence we
don't have
all the personnel to to make that
a situation where nobody can come over
the fence and onto the field but
again uh hopefully we got through it
without any
ill effects is brian kelly notre dame
head coach fresh off the win over
clemson at bc coming up next saturday
when you face clemson and in your mind i
guess you have to be prepared to face
them again in the acc title game do you
put everything out there like you want
to win that you needed to win this game
how much do you reveal of your game plan
playbook in a game like that and try to
hold something back
if you meet them in the acc title game
well dan i think it now becomes a game
of adjustments right it's it's what you
did in the game
uh and and what they did defensively and
and each team now is looking at how are
they going to make adjustments for
example
um you know what wrinkles will we have
in our protection you know what are they
going to do differently
uh that they did in the red zone against
us so i think this is
in if we do in fact play each other
it'll be much more about what
adjustments will you
make uh to your game plan uh
more so than anything else in the second
matchup if in fact we're lucky enough to
get there
who does uh trevor lawrence remind you
of
oh man i mean you know he he has
the athletic ability to to run like any
of the great running quarterbacks
um that that we've seen out there um
he's just a hybrid player he's got great
size
arm talent he could look i mean
i think he's that unique of a player
that that he is the number one pick in
the draft because
he's hard to compare like it's easy like
when you ask me about other players i
can immediately give you a name of a
player and say he's like this
it's hard to compare him to somebody
because he's got great athletic ability
but nobody has the length
and nobody has you know the similar
traits that he has i just think he's
a guy that doesn't come around very long
reminds me of andrew luck
well he's got the makeup of an andrew
luck uh
andrew as you know was bigger and
thicker and stronger
you know from that standpoint much more
of a pocket guy
um you know i i think luck is is going
to be
seen in the nfl as a guy with with great
escapability
and they're gonna move him around a
little bit you'll see him run as well
you always hear this there's a big win
and then you got next week
and then everybody says oh there's gonna
be a letdown so how do you tell your
kids
don't let down against bc
yeah so you know what's a letdown a
letdown is now living up to the
standards that we have set here for the
last
four years right i mean so it's been the
consistent application of our process so
all of a sudden we're going to go away
from what has been consistent
for us um i just you know
our guys are too smart for that they
know how to prepare
we'll go back out on the practice field
and and we'll prepare the right way
and play a very gritty tough
well-coached
boston college team and look we know the
history last time
notre dame beat a number one team they
played bc and lost
so we get all that we we read the
newspapers we know the the history clips
so
our guys are cognizant of it they'll go
out practice hard and they'll prepare
the right way
coolest thing in your office is what
uh i have a surfboard on my ceiling
because well who would ever have a
surfboard in south bend
i mean when when parents come into an
office you got to have something that's
a little bit different to talk about so
if you come in the office and never do
that coach and you look up and there's a
surfboard you got to say wow this is a
little bit different in south bend
well lake michigan can get a little
turbulent there but uh
yeah that's true but i'm trying to
compare i know harbaugh doesn't have a
surfboard
[Laughter]
he's got other things to worry about in
his office there
all right
i'm not touching that yeah smart
well done uh hey congrats on the win
good luck against bc thank you coach
all right take care dan that's uh brian
kelly notre dame head coach
at bc coming up this weekend they move
up from number four
to number two